يعني مثلا انا اسال من تطبيقات واجد اوكي
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح نزلت تغريده قبل كم شهر عن
اهتمامي بالتطبيقات البنكيه وكيف اني
مهبوس بالبحث عن افضل تجربه ممكن فعندي
البنك في اكثر من دوله بس عشان اشوف كيف
التطبيق والخدمات اللي عندهم مشترك في
خدمات مصرفيه ماليه كثيره بس عشان اجرب
كيف ترتفع جوده حياتي مع هذه التطبيقات
لكن في مشكله المشكله اني اجرب هذه
الخدمات وانقهر انقهر انها غير متوفره
عندنا تنزل جوده حياتي اكثر من قبل مرحله
البحث
الاماكن العامه او سياره اوبر توصل بسرعه
بيغض النظر عن جنسي
اول وسيله الدفع لكن
لدعاني لهذه الحلقه
وكيف اقيس صرف الشهري وين فلوس تروح وابغى
ادوات سهله تساعدني
في هذه المشكله والحديد طويل وهو مو مجرد
تطبيق واحد وفكره واحده هي بيئه تشريعيه
ممكنه تساعد رواد الاعمال انهم يبدعوا في
مشاريع مختلفه لحلول ساعدنا في ترتيب
حياتنا والضبط مصاريفنا ورفع نسبه ادخار
والاستثمار للافراد بالطريقه اللي تضمن
لنا الحرير الماليه لحياه كريمه الحلقه مع
صديقي سلطان الخيال مؤسس تطبيق دراهم
ومهتم بالتقنيه عموما والتقنيه الماليه
خصوصا الحلقه ممكن تخليك تحمل دراهم او
ممكن تحمل غيره ممكن تحمل تمره ابيان
علاقه او ممكن
تعطيك فرصه انك تفتكر الخدمه تسهل علينا
حياتنا
قبل ان نبدا فيه بوت كاست رائع اسمعه
لاهتمامي بمجال رياده الاعمال والشوق اسمه
فودكاست السوق فودكاست اسبوعي مصري جدا
وممتع وانصح فيه قوه
اما الان
لنبدا
الحين
بس
مستعد ااه مش عارف التقنيه يعني هسه
بتقنيه صارت كل شيء اول كانت الاس دي كارت
يعني اشياء تقنيه بس اليوم تقنيه صارت
نستخدم التقنيه زياده يعني يا اخي هل صار
فيها رتابه ولا احنا اللي تعودنا
لان اول كنت تتحمس اشوفه ايش نزل جديد
الحين
وبس
الحاجه همم موجوده
[موسيقى]
يجي في بالي انه يمكن لا الكريب 2
والخرابيط هذه وشو اللي انترنت عام 200
اني اخاف اني ما القط الجو
يصير كبير
ما عرفتك
في جزء من الراحه
بس ما بدي يصير اللي
راح عليه
كده ادخل يعني ودي
مثلا يمكن انه ما لقيته همم
[موسيقى]
يا بنتي وصلت لي يا اخي يعني
هذا تريند قاعد اشوف يصير كثير
تقنيه جديده ولا مسمه جديد والناس ياخذونه
ويقر هو والمستقبل اللي ما وخوف انك تصير
الشايب اللي ما يقتنع بالتقنيه الجديده
يسبب ان الناس يصيرون اكستريم من ناحيه
انه لا الويب 3 اؤمن فيه اشياء ما هي
منطقيه في الموضوع لا هو انت عشان انك
شايب ترى انت ما انت فاهم نفس الشيء
اني اشتري ارض في المتر يا اخي
الناس كانوا يقولوا يقولون التقنيه
الحقيقه ما لها قيمه الاراضي بس
وصلنا للمرحله اكس 3 لدرجه اللي اي حاجه
اي فكره غريبه مستنكره صرنا نحاول نخليها
اوه لا هي فعلا
في المدارس
في النرجس ههه
القيمه هل فعلا يعني اوكي في في اشياء
فعلا زي على قولتك كلمه الواحد قاعد يطلع
منها بشيء وانا قاعد يطلع منها بشيء ما
ادري بس يعني مو معقوله برضه استثمار متى
وذاكر بيرك
فيرس وكيف انه يحط البارح 10 مليار دولار
ويكون استثمار خطا
يمكن يطلع خطا ههه
اليوم احنا عليه اصلا ههه
لا تكلم انجليزي
واغلب يعني حياتي تتم عن طريق الانترنت
بشكل افتراضي همم
معك وخلص شغلي وانت جالس في كافه او ممكن
حتى انك متاكد
واتوقع هذه هذه القيمه ولا الفجر
هو اقدر اخلص شغلي افضل طريقه ممكن
النظاره
بطريقه افضل ولا بيصير الموضوع حسام
واتوقع هذا هذا البيت هنا حق فيسبوك
ماركنه لا بيكون قريب للحقيقه لدرجه اللي
وجودنا في نفس المكان مع بعض مالح السبب
كبير يعني زي الحين الحين بتوقع بعد كرونه
كيف الاجتماعات اللي صار ضروري
يعني
الدوله الثانيه
سمعت افتراضيه تاخذ شكل مو حقيقي اتفق
100% وتوقع هذا الهواش اللي صاير حاليا
لانه هل الشغل يكون عن بعد ولا الشغل يكون
في مكان واحد افضل كل واحد لها ارائه بس
اتوقع الجميع
بس تواصل بالكلام ولا هو تواصل بالتاكسي
يعني تحتاج التواصل على مراحل مختلفه هل
النظارات هذه بتتوصلنا للمرحله ولا لا في
كثير ناس مؤمنين لدرجه يخون مليارات
المليارات والاستثمارات انه لا في مرحله
بنوصلها بيصير ما تقدر تفرق بين الواقع
بالحقيقه وفي ناس يقولون لا يعني هذا
الشيء مستحيل انه هو صحيح لانه بيحتاج
اشياء مره كثير واشياء ما تقدر
اسهل لانه خلاص مسافر وتجيء يعني اقتصاديه
يعني
ممكن يونس هون فيسبوك
يعني كيف انه يبغاك تعيش
كاني معك بس مجرد بس النظاره الواقع
الافتراضي
يعني
انه بدنا نجتمع كل واحد في الدوله
ويصير كان نجتمعنا حقيقي يعني انا شفت
الفيديوهات حقيقي
في هذه احس نظريتين منطقيه تمام منظر
النظريه اللي اوكي والا لا
التقنيه بتتوسع لهذه المرحله وفيه اللي لا
التقنيه بتقعد زي ما هي وفي لها حدود وما
نقدر نسويها وفي الجنون اللي قاعد يصير
هون ههه قدام صارت واقعيه طيب انا بشتري
ارض من الحين عشان بعدين قيمتها بتصير
عاليه ولا انا بشتري
ارضيه وانه يصير قيمتها عاليه لانه المتر
بيكون شيء حقيقي احنا للحين ما وصلنا
للمرحله ديك وليه ما نوصل المرحله هذيك
ليه ما تصير الاشياء واقعيه نبدا نسوي
الواقع الافتراضي اللي تقدر تشتريه فيه
الحين كلها على امل انه همم
يخوف مثلا
نابع من انه اسمع انا ابغى اشوف المستقبل
ابغى الحق على المستقبل ونوقف نستخدم
عقولنا ههه
فعلا لها ابليكيشنز جدا منطقيه وتحل مشاكل
موجوده
والسنتراليزيشن والطريقه بتتحرك الاموال
في في لها اشياء منطقيه جدا بس فيها شيء
قاعد تخرب على الشيء المنطقي وكل احد قاعد
يخش عشان في المستقبل انا ببدا ابشر
بالاشياء هذه
قلت خلاص
بصير يعني
اللابتوب حقي زين
فتره كانت قابلت علينا يعني اعلاناتها الي
في 2016
القادم هو كمبيوتر القادم هو الكمبيوتر
فيقول لها وين البيسي حقك فهو يستغرب مش
بي سي اصلا اه فكيف كان رهان الايباد وهو
بده يصير شيء وطالع لانه فعلا
اولاد
اخواتي الصغار
فما يعرف يستخدم
يعني ادوات المحترفين عرفت كيف التسجيل
المبرمجه
هذه صعب جدا تتبدل لانه كده
بصنعت ان في عندك اكثر من شيء لازم تجمع
بينهم تحتاج الشعور
لكن الايباد يسوي 90 80% من المهام اللي
كل احد يحتاج يعني انت اعجبتني مثلا
مدرستي اختي على سبيل المثال
ما يعني اكيد من زمان اخت صغيره
وصلت للمرحله خلاص
وفعلا كل شيء قدره تسويه على الفيفا لدرجه
مثلا يعني موقع فلاشه
[موسيقى]
اتوقع شيء طبيعي جدا انهم يعيشون عليها
بشكل كبير ادوات المحترفين هي اللي عليها
علامه استفهام يعني
احيانا
سرعه يعني
احب الكمبيوتر
على ايباد ولا شيء طيب على الناس اللي تحب
تغير انا بغير السالفه وبدخل على تغيير
حياتي يلا الحين ااه في مصاريف والحمره
م ونواف حريري مسويه مصاريف
كم نسبه كم في نسبه الناس اللي متعوده
يعني مصاريف وما قدروا يجون دراهم مصاريف
المشكله ما عندنا بيانات عن المصاريف لكن
استهدفنا الناس اللي يستخدمه المصاريف
اه ويجون ياخذون بياناتهم المصاريف
يحولونها كلها على دراهم حطينا الخيار هذا
طبعا بعد ما ناسجه الطلبه كان عندي بيانات
سجلتها في مصاريف وابو انقل في استيراد
ونسبه ملابس المصاريف يعني
انا شخص يعني
الاجهزه كثير من الناس من الناس الصغار
الناس الكبار
اتوقع التقنيه بشكل
انه انا اقدر اوصل شيء سويته
فقد زر صار في المتجر كل احد يحمله كل حد
يشوفه وكل حديثه يمكن اجابه شويه سطحيه
لكن من جد
انه تقدر تحل مشاكل الناس على عدد جدا جدا
كبير ومشكله شخصيه زي مشكله اداره الاموال
هذا بالنسبه للرقم واحد انه اوكي
اعرف اسوي برامج اشتغلت مع شركات كثير
الفتره اللي راحت اوكي الحين ابغى حل
مشكله حقيقيه توصل العدد اكبر عدد ممكن من
الناس اداره الاموال هي المشكله اللي وقعت
عليها اللي الى الان اعتقد انها ما انحلت
همم مو بس في السعوديه عالميه همم
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر في
تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه
وذكاء سلوشن سباي اس تي سي
[موسيقى]
الموضوع
يصلح لك اياه
والحلول التقنيه الموجوده
كلها ادوات موجوده يلا ادخل البيانات وانا
بعطيك ال همم
اوكي همم
فنان رومانسي
[موسيقى]
ترتيب مصري في صفيات كلها غالبا الحين ما
في الا اللي واحد يعني كده في تويتر وعنده
متابعين مره كثير ويعطيك نصائح لكن يعني
ابو صالح
معك
بطريقه
وكل واحد عنده اهداف مختلفه ممكن
احد مختلف
ما تقدر تسويه حل يتابع المصاريف بس هي حل
متكامل من المتابعه للتخطيط للمشهوره
المثال اللي دراهمي
مش بيخليه عليه هناك شخص تعال اعطنا وضعك
المالي اربط بحساباتك واحنا بنرتبه امورك
انت تبي تبي تبي تملك بيت في الاخير
همم هل انت تبغي تتحقق الحريه الماليه
وانا اقدر اصير اتقاعد بمبلغ معين واقدر
اكمل عليه اوكي تمام
بالاخير هو انت ايش هدفك انت ايش اللي
تبغى تسويه همم نعطيك ادوات تساعدك على
الانتخابات
انا في مكتبه جرير يا اخي وعاجبني الجوال
هذا اوكي رصيدي في اقدر اشتري حل المفروض
اني اشتري طب اسمعي اذا انت اشتريت هذا
ترى انت قاعد تاخذ من ميزانيه السياره
اللي انت تبغاها بعد سنه بعد سنتين هل
مستعد انك تصحي اوك ممكن الواحد يقول انا
ابغى الجوال هذا الحين لكن ما في اداه
الحين تعطيك الاجابه هذا بشكل سريع ما في
حد يشور عليك يا اخي اشتري ولا ما اشتري
كل واحد على شعوره وعلى احساسه وعلى
السعاده اللحظيه اللي موجوده همم
وكل حاجه بدون تدخل بشري وبدون شغل زياده
لازم تسوي
تتوقع ان التقنيه بتحلها ليش لان
انا كنت استخدم من دوت كوم
وطبعا يعني قدرته على الربط وقدرت له
قديمه الظاهر من 2000 صح ما شاء الله عليه
مستحويل كان موجود قبل كم وموقع وبعدين
تحول تطبيق
فهو يعني متقدم جدا همم تقنيه
وفكره ثانيه يسوي نفس الدراهم صح اه بس
بشكل
انك تستخدمه فهو يقدر يربط بين البنوك انا
محتاج اني اعبي البيانات يعني هو بيدخل
على البنك حقي وياخذ البيانات من اللي
جلسات تصير مباشره
ويقدر يصنفها وتصنيف نقاط البيع في امريكا
دقيقه عكس اللي هنا ممكن تلقى
بقاله يسجل نفسه محطه علشان يتفاد
لانه في دعم المحطه مثلا
[موسيقى]
موجوده ف- اا ومع ذلك ما قدرت يعني يمكن
كده يقول لك تبغى تسافر جمع
ففيه طريقه علشان تجمع الرحلات فيها ابريل
مثلا
احس اني ما قدرت اتغلب على سلوكي السيء في
قدره على ضبط المصاريفي رغم انها تقنيه
متكامله همم
ترى حتى في امريكا على اساس انه تعتقد انه
الموضوع سهل انه اقدر
احللها شيء لا كيف كيف سوى تصنيف البدايه
عندهم يعني
حطيتها كلها وخلاص
بدات
لكن هذا انتم
حساباتك بناءا على الرابط
[موسيقى]
زي كده
اللي قاعد نحاول نسويهم جزء كبير منه من
نفس ما انت نربط مع حسابك البنك نصنف بشكل
تلقائي نعطيك تقرير عن صرفياتك وضعك
الماليه تمام لكن المرحله الثانيه اللي
تجي طب خلاص انا عرفت وضعي المالي هل
نعتمد عليك انك انت تصحح وضعك المالي بشكل
كبير لو كل هالطريقه
فكثير من الناس ما هي عارفه كفايه وانا
منهم يعني ايش الشيء اللي اسويه عشان انه
ب- احدد هدفي ولا احقق شيء همم في كده
تقدر تقول اساسيات الواحد اللي هو الدخان
بشكل صحيح صحيح
انه همم اسوي ميزانيه ميزانيات تكون
محكومه واعرف انا هذه وين رايحه وتكون
كلها متكامله وتلقائيه لانه دائما اللي
يقتل الرقظه في التحسين اي احتكاك يكون
موجود
حطيت بياناتي همم اوكي انا لازم احطها كل
يوم خلاص ثاني يوم همم امشي
مع البنك لازم
احط انا الميزانيه واختار الاشياء
وبتخلي الفلوس
عمليه كلها نربط حسابك نعطيك تقرير نعطيك
الاقتراح وننفذ
نقول اوكي انت تبغى توفر همم 100,000 عشان
همم هدف معين طيب اسمع عشان تحقق الهدف
هذا لازم كل شهر تحط لي 1,000 ريال في همم
في محفظه وثابته خلاص انا رابط مع حسابك
البنكي فاقدر اني اخذ ال1000 هذه كل شهر
واحطها لك اذا انت تبغى تسحبها فتجيء تقول
لي اه بسحبك اسمعي لما تسحبها بتروح من
هذاك الهدف بيتاخر بفتره معينه اوكي فتبدا
تسوي قرارات
باداه تساعد فعلا
البساطه
تنزيل الاحتكاك مع كل الخطوه نخلي عندك
اداه تقدر انك تدخل وتستثمر الشخص اللي
يقول طبعا ما عندي هدف دخلي كويس واموري
تمام واشرب قهوه الصباح مبسوط ولا ابوفر
ولا هذا طيب اوك عندك اللي هو هدف التوفير
والاستثمار الفلوس انها قاعده في حساباتك
هذا ما هو شيء صحيح يعني الحين البنك
المركزي تقرير
الشكنج اكاونت اللي حسابات الجاريه في
السعوديه وصلت الى واحد فاصله ثلاثه مليون
غلط
قال اقل الايمان لما تيجي اوك على وضعي
تمام انا ما باسوي ميزنيات انا ما باسوي
شيء اوكي تمام طيب عندك
اقترحت تلقائي انه كل شهر بناخذها
وبنستثمرها لك وانت تحدد المخاطره تقول
ابو مخاطره عاليه ابو مخاطرك قولي لو قلنا
عليها
تمام
ضعيف يعني
نسبه المفهوم يعني مفهوم الادخار
والاستثمار لكن الله يعين لكن ودي ارجع
باخذ النقاط حتى بحبك
فاول شيء قلت انك تربط مع البنوك
احنا يا طويل العمر رابطين تقريبا بشكل
مباشر مع اربع بنوك السعوديه الراجحي
الاهلي الرياض والعرب غريبه انا دخلت ما
هو ما هو مطلق الان اللي مطلق حاليا البنك
العربي فقط بنك العربي بنك العربي
بنك المستقبل
ههه
طيب باسم الكرب العربي وايش كانت المشكله
ليش ما في للبنك العربيه في المصرفيه
المفتوحه
يعني ليش ما تقدر تضبط مع البنوك كلها
الحين ما هم مسموح يطلق دكتور كامل
ديسمبر السنه الماضي
كان الهدف حق المصرفيه المفتوحه الربع
الثاني السنه هذه تاخر للربع الثالث تتاخر
للربع مع بعض
انه البيانات البنكيه ملك للعميل ما هي
ملك للبنك فانا يا العميل اقدر اقول اعطيه
بياناتي تراهم انا اسمح بالشيعه
وهذه من البنك المركزي انه يخلي هذا
الفكره موجوده في البيانات كثير
بنك الراجحي ولا عند بنك الاهلي
حي البيانات حول يعني حاليا عند البنك
بيانات العملياتك هويتك الايبان حقك
والاشياء هذه
انه انا اقدر
بربط التقني اا اصرح لاي جهه تاخذ بياناتي
اقدر اسحبها من البنك تقدر تسحبها من
البنك عندك شخص تقدر تسحبها من البنك طبعا
لكن فتح حسابي يمكن مثلا
وفي اصلا
اكمل مده لكن البنك مطالب انه يترك يعني
سجل الحساباتك اللي فتره معينه حتى بعد
اغلاق
البنك المركزي همم
[موسيقى]
يقول لازم يكون عندك مركز بيانات مخزن في
السعوديه
الان مع البيانات المفتوحه المفترض ان
البنك لا يستطيع تخزين بيانات انا ما ابغى
يخزن
هذه هذه
الخصوصيه البيانات
مسجله في البنك البنك ما اقدر اقول له
اعطيها افلام حاليا البنك
موجوده
في موجود عند البنك الراجحي ما اقدر
اصدرها الا بكشف حساب بطريقه مانيوال يعني
واقدر اعطيها لاحد الاول لكن ما اقدر
اسويها بطريقه تقنيه لانه خلاص اقدر اجيب
بياناتي كلها واعطيها بشكل سهل هذا اللي
يتغير الحين انه انا عميل عندي الحق اني
اقول بنك الراجحي اعطيها طبعا كلها هذا
احنا نتكلم
البوليس في دراهم
موجود كل البنوك الامارات تقدر تربط معها
رابط مباشر بينهم السعوديين في البنك
العربيه هذه للمشرع المشرع المفتوحه
عندهم رابط مباشر
هو فكره مي يدخل على
الحسابك في الانستغرام البيانات بدون
تنظيم بدون تشريع بدون شيء خاص يدخل ويقدر
يسوي العمليات هذا عشان كذا دقه البيانات
تكون اقل السرعه تكون ابطا بكثير لانها
يعني يسمونه هاكي يعني بطريقه ما هي شرعيه
عشان اخذها لكن العميل يعطيك صلاحيه ويوضح
له يعني انه ترى انا بسوي كذا بسوي كذا
وباخزنها ومو اي حد يقدر يسويها في
الامارات
فا هذا اللي صاير في الامارات احنا ما
ربطنا مع البنوك 16 بنك بشكل مباشر لا
ربطنا عن طريق مزود خدمه مزود خدمه وهو
مصرح هناك ويجيب لك البيانات
في السعوديه تذكر هشام الفالح كان يقول
يعني انه يوم البنوك السعوديه كلهم كذا
يعني رافضين ولا هم اعطينا اي اعتبار
لانه البنك المركزي بيطلب منك انك تقفل
الموقع بشكل سريع مره مخالفه يعني في
الامارات عام فيها في السعوديه
البنك المركزي قال انا ما بخليها بالطريقه
العشوائيه هذه وبخليها بطريقه منظمه
وبستاند وتكون عن طريق اي بي اس اي احد ما
يقدر يطلقها عن طريق السكري
قال في مصرفيه مفتوح
من البنوك الوحيد اللي كانت تقنيه جاهزه
مفتوحه
البي كما هي همم
بعدين جاءت مرحله ثانيه همم انه خلاص لا
في مواصفات معينه لازم ترجع لي اسم المحل
الحال لازم ترجع لي وهذه كلها يعني تكنك
السافيكيشن خلص مواصفات تقنيه لازم
يتبعونها وشوي شوي اااه يعني كان البنك
المركزي صراحه بطريقه عمله على المصرفيه
المفتوحه
سواه بافضل طريقه ممكنه يعني في طريقه
للعشوائيه خلاص انت الشركه وهذه دائما
الفري ماركت اللي الواحد يقدر يروح ويسوي
شيء بشكل سريع وخلاص وفي الطريقه المثلث
للموضوع انه لا خلاص احنا نتفق على همم
بيانات السوق يحتاجها على همم
دراهمي واحد ثاني يبغى يصير يطلع لك شهاده
الراتب يصير هذه كلها تقدر
تحليل البيانات
اه في اليوم تقدر تسوي شركه تنافس تعطيك
لا ترفيه اللي هو احنا انت حاليا كشركه
عاده اذا تبي تقدم على مناقصه ولا شيء
لازم يكون عندك الشهاده اللي تضمن انه
عندك مبلغ معينه في البنك فهذا لازم تروح
البنك الحين لا خلاص اقدر اربط مع بنكك
الشركه بشكل مباشر واصرح لك شيء هذا عن
طريق المصرفيه المفتوحه وفي ثنتين صراحه
ثانيه ما ما تحظرني حاليا لكن جماعه وحطوا
الكيسس وقالوا ايش البيانات اللي بنحتاجها
بناءا على البيانات هذه طيب ايش نشرب على
البنوك المعلومات اللي يوفرونها لازم
يوفرون المعلومات هذه لازم الزاميه
والعربي والاهلي والرياض هذا اللي احنا
رابط
انه يجي من كل البنوك اللي في السعوديه
السعوديه وغير السعوديه انا اساسن
بالبيانات مفتوحه اي بنك مصرح له بالعمل
في السعوديه لازم يكون ان كلودينج سي سي
على فكره اه
اه على نهايه السنه هذه ديسمبر همم اغلب
البنوك اكثر من 80% اكدت جاهزيتها باذن
الله
للاستاندرز السعوديه انها تطبق باذن الله
اسامه اعلنت رسميا انه بدايه السنه
القادمه همم في الربع الاول بيكون الاطلاق
الرسمي المفتوح
كويس سواها بالطريقه الممثله اللي تجيك
البيانات بطريقه كويسه تضمن حق العميل
يعني العميل صار عنده يسمونه
انا اقدر اعطيك دراهم تصريح واقدر اسحبه
منك ثاني يوم ولازم تستسلم يوفر لي شيء
هذا ولا ما تكون اقدر اعطيك تصريح مره
واحده فقط اقدر اعطيك تصريح لمده معين
واقدر اشيل التصريحات سووه بطريقه مرتبه
ومنظمه
همم راحوا حطوا القوانين بقدر ما قال جابه
البنوك جابوا الشركات اللي تبغى تسويه همم
يعني تطبيقات على المصرفيه المفتوحه وقاعد
يسوون ورش امل ورش اعمال وستاندرز طيب ايش
رايكم كده طيب ايش رايكم كده وبعدين ترفع
اسئله وبعدين سووا مختبر فسووها يعني كان
في شغل صراحه سنتين يتم رائع واكثر من
رائع ويبرر التاخيرات اللي صار
كم دوله عندها المسرفين المفتوحه
اتوقع في اكثر من دوله في الدول يعني زي
امريكا مثلا
وفي الدول مثلا زي بريطانيا
تاخذ البيانات بس لازم تكون بطريقه بطريقه
موجوده
ولا ادري جسر ولا يسمح لي اني اطلعها عشان
استخدم خدمات ثانيه
يعني فهموه بس هذا لا بياناتي تصير ملكه
ولا ادري اذا انا ودي اسمح لي انه يشوفها
اصلا الصراحه او نعالجها فاللي متحمس لها
اكثر من بيناتهم
مثلها اكثر
يعني هو قانون البيانات اللي
اصدرت اصدرته
ما اصبح قانون نافذ
السنه الجايه
فهو مهم لاني عارف مين يعني دراهم اذا
بيعالج بياناتي هيك
اذا
اذا عندك يجيبني ادري انك
بالقانون
100% اتذكر اااه يعني مثلا انا ازعل من
تطبيقات واجد اوكي
[موسيقى]
طيب البيانات فين تخزن البيانات وين طيب
اقدر احذف المايك طيب كيف اضمن انحذفت
وفعلا الاسئله صح كيفهم فهمم
ما ادري والله شلون الواحد
يلتزم فيها هذا هو يعني اتوقع لمرحله
معينه لازم في ثقه لانه خاص في مشرع
والمشرع هذا بيشرف عليك
وخلال يعني دائما يكون عندك مراجعات وهمم
اوراق لازم تقدمها تثبت انه انت ملتزم
وجزم التزام هذا انك تحذف همم
يلا تريتو يا هلا والله انا خالد القحطاني
وانا عبيد الله العيسى بدانا معكم مرتده
في البوت كاسي الرياضي اللي يحلل اهم
احداث الكره السعوديه كسبنا من خلال ثقتكم
وتفاعلكم والمركز الاول في كل حلقه الشيخ
خلانا نطمح بنا نتقدم خطوه
المونديال هو اكبر موسم دراما من يوم
انولدت الكوره قبل 150 سنه بدات في مسيرته
رونالدو
مثل زين الدين زيدان
عشان كده قررنا ناخذ خطوه جديده ونكون
معكم صوت وصوره في مونديال 2022 الحدث
النادر في كل شيء تقريبا هذه اول مره يقام
في بلاد عربيه هذه ايضا اول مره يقام
بتوقيت هنا الشتوي والاهم من ذلك ان هذا
المونديال هو بمثابه الرقصه الاخيره
بلاعبين عظيمين جدا بقيمه كريستيانو
رونالدو وليونيل ميسي راح نحلل معكم افكار
مدربين ونقف فيه على كل جمله
مع منتخب الوطني اللي بيشارك للمره
السادسه واحنا نستمتع كلنا جميعا باجواء
مونديال 2022 في طريقتنا اللي تعودتم
عليها وحبيتها كوب قهوه وسواليف بتحليل
الدقيق وارقام مستدله تابعونا في كاسده
على قنوات 8 كما نصرت البوتاس واليوتيوب
طيب الحين من البينات بدي اعرف تقدر تعرف
وين اكثر الناس يصرفون
بالنسبه للناس
يعني فكره انا ادري انه البنوك مصر
البيانات كلها
سعيد
وبعدين خلال اسبوع
سويناها يعني من فكره
كلام كلام عليها
وهي اكثر من مرحله انه كيف نقدر نحضر
رسائل بس اسهل طريقه نحللها نصنعها
يعني كان نقش وحاجه كبيره انه نطلع بالسوق
قبل ما يعني
فكان عندنا دائما انه كيف كيف كيف كيف كيف
كيف كشف الحساب لازم ضروري
ما في طريقه سهله والى الان يعني هذه امثل
طريقه لقيناها بس ترى صادق والله يعني همم
ارسلت لك كثير مره يعني انا لان كل عمليه
هو يعني انت مخليها لنا يقرا الرساله فيها
فلوس انسخه
بس كل مره لازم اضغط موافق
يعني وممكن مره تضبط
اللي انا بربط مع البيك مباشر
في ناس ما شاء الله تبارك الله اللي عندهم
الجلد
بشكل مره كبير تحسين التجربه همم يعني
فبننا لما الرب يكون جاهز على اكمل وجه
فيكون عندنا منتج مجرب همم يعني
يرد التصنيفات قاعد ما تتصور قديش
التصنيفات تحسنت فقط من الرسائل ومن هذا
يعني اذكر مره كيف قرطبه بقاله في الزاويه
رحت وصرفته وحطيتها درهم قال لي انها
بقاله يعني مستحيل
طبعا احنا عندنا اكثر من همم شغله انه على
حسب الاسم على في كلمات مفتحيه نستخدمها
وبالاخير في عندنا الانججن اللي هو اللي
على على البيانات موجوده عندنا ههه
مع واحد من الاصدقاء في احد البنوك
وكان يقول انهم برضه البنوك يتزوج نقاط
البيع يعني وكان واحد من البنوك اللي
عندها نقاط عاليه كان يقول انه احنا نبغى
نطلق التحليل البيانات
كان يقول ما نقدر لان البيانات مش صحيح
الي في السوق فاحنا اللي جالسين نسوي الان
انه نبغى نرتب السوق في انه كل نقاط بين
نتاكد انها حقيقيه
فاذا مغسله مكتوب
عليها
كده عشان لما احط لك البيانات
بس بس صدقني بدي اعرف كيف
استغربت همم مقدراتكم في همم والله يعني
سواء كيف يطلع شعر شركه
استرداد النقدي
لما يجيني كاشباك
فاتح تونسي
يعني كل البنوك السعوديه كيف تتعامل مع
رسائل ولا
كانت هذه الطريقه اللي في البدايه انه
اوكي نحاول بس اكتشفنا في كميه رسائل
مستحيل تمر عليك في حياتك يعني
والكيسز مختار هذا فبنينا يعني
عندنا اثنين علماء بيانات قاعدين وبنان
على البيانات اللي موجوده اخذنا الرسائل
ده ربنا المحرك هذا وبناءا عليه صار يتعطف
على نوع الرساله وهل هيك
تصنيفها بلاش هذه كلها وكل البيانات اللي
جايه ترى جايه
فهذه كلها
مع الوقت
لكن الناس فعلا اللي عندها جلد والله
يعطيهم الف عافيه
ويصنفون ويجعل نحاول يسهل لهم يعني خلاص
بضغطه يقدر يعدل بضغطه يقدر يعني نساعده
يساعدنا ههه
هذا اللي اشتغلته اشتغلت بطريقه ما
توقعناها انها بهالسرعه يعني صراحه انه
فعلا التصنيفات تتحسن به الطريقه قراءه
رسالتكم عن طريق بس كلها يعني اوكي طيب كم
عدد
المستخدمين الحين
عدد المستخدمين يا طويل العمر 30
الرقم هذا ولا سوينا دعايه ولا حاجه ترى
كلها حرفيا لولو وين دعايات ولا شهد تيجي
ان شاء الله بعد الربط المباشر
وتوافق كم عندهم مصاريف نواف لا ما سالت
ما ما اتوقع نواف ما عندها احصائيات اصلا
يعني ههه
يعني تطبيقات سيئه مهما كبرت كثره فلوسها
انا اتذكر كنت اشتكي ايام كريم
اييي الحمد لله على كل حال يعني دائما
تعبرون السعوديين باننا
ليش اجلس تسوي تطبيق زي الناس او
السعوديين ما ما يعجبهم تصميم حلو وهم
يعجون مخيسه
والله ما ادري يعني تفتح عندي تطبيق
ازمه تفكر يا رجل انا احس كده دائما مستوى
الجوده عندنا منخفض للاسف بشكل مره كبير
ولا في محفز يتحسن على قولت خلصنا من
الناس تستخدم دائما
اتوقع اللي بيحل المشكله هذه المنافسه
الكبيره لما يجي احد يحاول يرفع المستوى
هذا تصير ذائقه الناس ما تتقبل شيء همم
الله يعطيك العافيه
كمان دقيقه
احنا ثمانيه الحين تقريبا بس خليكم نتفق
عليها فقط 100% 100
قديش نحن قاعدين نحاول يعني نقاوم مراقبه
التوسع ههه لانه تحس انه انا اقدر اصير
اسرع بمجرد اني اضيف احد زياده ولكن
بالخير تطلع تعقيدات وتطلع التواصل فريق
صغير سريع يتغير بسرعه ويتعدل بسرعه افضل
بكثير منك انت ما تتوقع همم
الاشخاص والاسر يتحول وانت جاي الى النوم
تكون اكثر
واسهل وبدون تعقيدات فمثلا هذا سله اه
وتقدر تشوف قدامك اليوم في تصريح واللي هو
معمل
ففي يعني مثلا تقدر تشوف
مثلا
العلاقه في البنوك بس انها همم
ادخل فلوس على طول
بينما دراهم هسه اقل يعني مساله تحليل
البيانات وضبط الدراهم
المحافظه الفلوس
فالناس تشترك والناس في في مستخدم زعل
علينا قلنا اسفين هذا اشتراك مجانا
فالهالدرجه احنا عندنا اشتراكات دائما
سمعتها سيئه لانه ما حد بيشترك ما حد
بيتفاعل معنا وفعلا على سكايل مره كبير
لكن حاليا في ناس لكن طبعا اموت عليك انه
الاشتراكات تجيب فلوس بقدر ما انه اذا
سويت تجربه ممتازه تحل مشاكل ماليه بتقدر
تطلع منها فلوس
في عندنا ثلاث مراحل احنا دائما بنتكلم
عنها مرحله الاولى نربط الحسابات البنكيه
نعطيك تحليلات تصفيات
الماليه المرحله الثانيه الاستثمار
التلقائي والتوفير التلقائي اللي هو يعني
خلاص عندك اهداف عندك
من وين
حضرتك
دراهم الطريقه السليسه الرهيب الواحد
ههه
هذه المرحله الثانيه ان شاء الله بتطلع
قريب المرحله الثالثه والاخيره اللي هي
المدفوعات والحوالات يعني شفنا انه نوع
العمليات اللي تم فيه دراهم اكثر من 50%
كلها حوالات داخليه حوالات بين حساباتي
حوالات الى بره في الناس تحول بشكل مره
كبير اصلا اكثر من 80% من الناس في
السعوديه عندهم اكثر
مشاكل مره كبيره عندك فواتير عندك اشتراك
تفاحه همم وكلها لازم اروح وادفعها كل شهر
في مدري اهلي انا احول لهم نهايه الشهر
فلازم اني احول ولا اني انسى ولا فتخيل لو
انه حساباتك اللي في مكان واحد تحول
حوالات كلها في مكان واحد تدفع فواتير
كلها في مكان واحد همم وتقدر تدفع من الاب
بشكل واحد يعني مكان واحد هذا الحلم
تطبيق مالي رهيب يكون مساعدتك الشخصي
دائما وابدا همم لكن نقدر نقول احنا
والولد تمام ههه
عداد الكهرباء
انا ما ادري وين تدور في البنك حقي
القاصدات
مسجل عندي
الرقم
زي كذا تبنى باساسات صحيحه تقدر تسوي
عليها تطبيقات كثيره جوالي
يمكن ال ال بالعربي
[موسيقى]
امريكيه بنك في امريكا غيرها همم فذكر فش
كنا نوار
هذا غالبا بيطلع لك اياها نقاط بيع شراء
فلانه للتاريخ الفلاني يعني يطلع لي
التواريخ نوع العمليه تصنيف العمليه صادر
ورد
القادمه هنحاول نعرف انه تراسمها شهر سته
عندك همم فاتوره عندك مصاري في العيال
عندك الاشياء هذه كلها
نعطيك اداء تحاول انها سهل يعني او تعطيك
المعلوم
[موسيقى]
قديش تقدر البنوك في انها همم
تصعب عليك الوصول للطموحك اوكي
ان عندهم تحليل البيانات
فعنده يعني تقدر
الميزانيه اضيف الميزانيه
فواتير الخدمات
هو اعطاني رقم 7 متوسط
احس الاكل
[موسيقى]
وانا اريدي انا جالس استخدم
التطبيق نفسه ونفس البنك
وبطاقتي عندهم
فليش اروح استخدم خدمه ثانيه يعني ليش
اطلع من مكانه رحت تعلم على شيء جديد
لطالما كل شيء عند نفسك البنك اللي انا
ادخل عليه نفس التطبيق اللي انا ادخل عليه
شوف النقطه الاول الاساسيه اللي جوده
التنفي احنا متفقين عليها يعني بالاخير
انه تفرق كيف الخدمه المقدمه
الثاني اكثر من 80% من السعوديين عنده
حساب البنك
تمام تمام
انا كان عندي اول اول حساب بنكي كان في
البنك الاهلي الاول البنك اطلع اوكي
وبعدين تركتها من زمان يعني تركته
فين 2011 اذا كل ما عاد استخدمته المهم
انه حساب مجمع
بعدين
مؤخرا تطبيق جديد جديد
الحمد لله
ههه
مميزات حلوه اتوقع انه همم كلفت النقل من
حساب او لما تيجي تموين فتبغى هذا بيعطيك
هنا اهلي موجودين
فاغلب الناس عندهم حسابين واذا بيكون حلول
يكون في خدمه اللي تقدر
هذه كلها هل في عندك مكان يا جماعه غالب
الناس
يعني هذه وحده من اللي فعلا يعني بدل مع
اني اطلع من تطبيق لتطبيق واروح خلاص
تطبيق واحد في اموالي كلها مو بس فيها
موالي واشوفها اقدر اسوي عمليات اقدر احول
من هذا لهذا واشوفها راحت اقدر ادفع اقدر
اسمع ترى الفاتوره الاتصالات الموجوده ضغط
زر اقدر اسددها بدل ما اني اروح اسدد شويه
من هنا واسدد شويه
هذه هذا الحلم بصراحه ههه انا ودي اشوفها
صراحه واقع لانه انا احتاجك شخص ومن اللي
شفناه صراحه من المستخدمين فعلا هذه برضو
حاجه موجوده وملحها بشكل كبير
البنوك قاعد تسوي كل حاجه واي حد يقدر
ينافس تعرف يعني الموضوع ما هو صعب ابدا
اصلا احنا نشوف كل يوم قاعد يطلع تطبيق
بالعكس
ونشوف يعني بس زي ما انت قلت ما هي على
كميه الفلوس اللي تضخ على
منتج واحد عشان تسوي افضل تجربه ممكنه هي
على مين بيقدر يسوي افضل تجربه هذه
التجربه اللي تعكس اصوات الناس وتحطها لهم
بافضل طريقه ممكنه وما بضروره انه ابغى
شيء فلاني وتحط لي اياه بقدر مع انه كيف
اضيف لك قيمه بشكل مباشر انت ليش تستخدم
تطبيق
يعني في البدايه في تحليل البيانات عشان
كده لما تبدا تستثمر فلوس زياده على شان
انا ادخلها
شلون انتم تحل ازمه التحويل
يعني مراحل المرحله الاولى بحلل بناء على
التحليل هذا باقول لك اسمع في عندك خطه
استثماريه تقدر انك تسويها
وانفذها بشكل تلقائي والخطوه الاخيره اللي
اخليك تدير اموال كلها من مكان واحد
مثلا
اللي هو المدفوعات القادمه
اسمع ترى احنا لاحظنا انك تحول للشخص هذا
كل شهر بهذا المبلغ
الحواله بدل ما انك تروح تسويه تقدر
هذه الفكره الاساسيه انه خلص يعني تطبيق
عملياتك البنكيه من مكان واحد بدل ما انها
تصير من اكثر
طيب
عدنان
الاستثماريه في ناخذ نسبه همم اداره
المدفعات عن طريق همم ناخذ
الطرق
طيب بدي اعرف فلسفه
اللي يشيل معك ههه
فلوس
هذه بتجيء هل في قيمه انت تبحثها ان واحد
بضيف قيمه كثير كل واحد بيعطيك فلوس يقول
عربي
قليل جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
همم وشيء ثاني انه شو اسمه يعني
الدعم منه هذا عقبه قليله وما في اي همم
محاضرات ولا حاجه تمنع انه اسوي اتفاقيه
ماشي صعبه
عندهم الفلوس اللي محتاجه
بسيط
بس مثلا انا ما احتاج
مثلا يعني اخذ ما احد دخل مستثمر فتره
طويله ما احد دخل المستشفى تعتبر
واحد مثلا
يمكن ما تحتاج احيانا لانك انت تبى تنمو
بشكل يعني وانت ما كنت تحتاج
صدقت انك تبني التطبيق قبل الحديث
بالكامل وحصلت على الرخصه من بنك المركزي
بدون
استثمارات
ما كان عندي هدف انه حديث يخلي انه وجع
راسي
تضيف لك بسهوله زي ما انت تتوقع همم
مباشر
بعيد المدى
عشان كده يعني اسالك يعني
جاهز هيكلت شركه تكون متوافقه يعني ترى
ميزانيه كبيره جدا ضخمه فقط على
البناء البنيه التحتيه صحيحه اللي هي
الامنه على فتحتها الفريق مني لك شيء هذا
كله والفريق هذا يحتاج تعطيه رواتب
والرواتب بتعرف يعني في السعوديه خاصه
الفريق كله سعودي همم تحتاج يعني مبلغ
كبير عشان تمشي رواتب هذه
همم انك ما تحتاج بالعكس
ااا ما هو يعتبر ريت قليل جدا ماهوريت
كبير همم اتوقع 60,000 70,000 دولار
ما هو شيء كبير
هذا الفريق صغير يعتبر ترى الفريق يعتبر
صغير ومعنا صارفيات غير الفريق بشكل مره
كبير لبناء المنتج يعني
اه
فبكده اتوقع ان يعني بيزيد
ليش تحتاجه
بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
بشكل مستمر
يعني مثلا واحد من التطبيقات يعني هذه
موثوقين
قدام حياه سوق المال للموثقيه قدام
الشركات والبنوك اللي احنا قاعدين نحاول
نربط معها هذه كلها تفرق يعني ما تقول
سنابل صندوق في المستثمر داخل معي
جدا جدا
[ضحك]
كانوا معها
مقابل 500,000 ريال اخذ دولار تقريبا
افكر بمشكله اداره الاموال ما هي مشكله
محليه فقط هي مشكله عالميه ااا
والدخول مستثمر زي واي سي اييي يعطيك
الموثوقيه هذه انه المشكله الي انت قاعد
تحلها مشكله موجوده مشكله عالميه ما هي
مشكله محليه فقط
ويفتح لك ابواب عجيبه بصراحه يعني
كانوا معنا نتكلم معاهم بشكل مستمر توم
اللي هو المؤسس همم حق موزه اول ديجيتال
البنك همم بريطانيا
الرجال
لما يجي واحد بس الموضوع هذا كله وتتكلم
معه بشكل
كبير لما تروح تتكلم مع الفاوندر لما
تتكلم
عظيمه جدا وتسمع خبراتهم بشكل حقيقي
واقعي ادى الى نجاح
بهذا الحاله قيمه غير طبيعيه ممكن نسويها
ااه واي سي مو فقط يعطوك استثمار ويعطيك
البرنامج بدا خلاص همم يساعدونك في كل
مراحل يشارك يساعدونك في المرحله اللي في
البدايه فتح الابواب واعطيك الخبرات عندهم
كتيب حرفيا لكل حاجه ممكن تحتاجه طب انت
بتفتح جوله استثماريه ايش الاشياء واشياء
واقعيه جدا بس موجوده
وفي تقييمات وتعليقات من الناس اللي حصلوا
على الاستثمارات منهم وايش التجارب
المختلفه الموجوده هذه بدايه مستحيل تحصل
عليها الا انها موجوده
همم والشجره الثانيه الوصول غير طبيعي
يعني مثلا مؤسس همم حبيت اتواصل معها فده
كتبت في مجتمع على طول الايميل لشخص عنده
من افضل الشركات بصراحه
اه مشاوي كثير فهذا كان السبب بصراحه وغير
كده دخلت في السعوديه يعني نحن نكون
المدخل الاول سيف السعوديه هذا شيء يفرح
امون نحن شخصيا
خليني اخليهم
يدخلون همم
لاني اقدر اشوف تجارب ثاني همم
يقولون 10 15
احنا اول مره يقلصون العدد 50% تقريبا
يعني في وقت قراءه يوم صار ريموت قبله حول
400 تقريبا
احنا اول سنه العدد يتقلص بشكل مره حلو
جدا
ويشرف عليها السلام
يعني خلاص
والاشياء اللي انت تقدر
الحين موجوده عليهم
[موسيقى]
هتبقى دقيقه دقيقه
دراهم اه
من قبل دراهم في اقواس بس هل انت اشتغلت
في اي وظيفه
يعني بعد ثاني سنه في اقواس طلعت اشتغلت
دوام جزئي فاقوس ورحت البنك الفرنسي
[موسيقى]
العمر
ههه جاءت مع السلامه سلام اهو شف تخرجت من
الجامعه وبدات اقواس على طول وقلت خلاص
باكمله بس جتني فتره همم يعني حرب شغل غير
طبيعي من الصبح لليل
درجه بدات تجيني بتسؤالات
القرار الصحيح هذا الشيء اللي قاعد يسوي
شيء انا واسوي ولا لا ما جربت اشتغل في اي
مكان ثاني فاذكر جت فرصه من البنك المركزي
برنامج حق همم سايبر كثير كثير اوكي
يختارون عدد قليل من الناس يودونهم
بريطانيا امريكا ياخذون مشاهده وبعدين
يروحوا يشتغل في بنك ولا حاجه زي كده فانا
كنت مختفي في الدوره هذه فتره اني اقعد
افكر فصل الدوره
هذه قلت اسمع اللي كنت اسويه هو شيء صح لا
لا
[ضحك]
تشوفوا النظيفه
[موسيقى]
لكن اتوقع
بطريقه العمل الرياده ان ال ال ال ال
المجال مفتوح بشكل كبير اتخذ قرار وتقدر
تنفذ القراره هذا وتشوفه واقع بعينيك همم
في الوظيفه غالبا ولما تكون في مكان مره
كبير انت عجله موجوده مهم وفي ناس فعلا
خلاص عندهم الراحه هذه وعندهم همم
منظمه كبيره
وعندك تحكم واطلب عليه بشكل مره كبير
هالقصه بسيطه
كنا نشتغل صراحه
همم
كنت في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
الناس حول العالم في في سحر فيه ههه
طيب بس
طيب كيف كان ندخلك وقتها في اقواس ممتاز
الحمد لله على السوق لانه اقواس كان
الراتب ما هو عالي لكن فيه ارباح نهايه
السنه توزع همم توازن تدخل بشكل ممتاز
فكملت انت فرجعت وكملت اقواس
بعدين طلعت وهمم بعد ست سنين تقريبا
يعني ايش اللي خلاك تطلع وتدخل هذه المره
بدل ما تسويها على الجنب
وانت جالس في اقواس على الجنب يعني ثبت
نجاح بعدين تطلع من الاقواس وتبدا التجربه
الجديده في قرعه
تعود لي شخصيا من نوع المخاطر كل شيء ولا
شيء فهذا واحد شيء ثاني خلال فتره اقواس
اشتغلت يعني مع ناس رهيبين جدا اه
وطلعت بخبرات مره ممتازه وشفت شركات تنمو
من مراحل صغيره لمراحل الكبيره واحنا كنا
بجنبهم يعني همم
وصلت الى مرحله اللي اوكي انا بدي اشوف
الاثر هذا بشكل مباشر بشكل اسرع ما ودي
انه يكون المطر اثر متوزع على اكثر من
شركه
قليل
الرغبه هذه هي اللي قال اوكي حاجه نقدر
نسويها مشكله حقيقيه نقدر نحلها تاثر فعلا
على ملايين الناس واقدر احرص بشكل كبير
واحط حياتي ووجهتي كلها
هي هي الاجابه تذكرك يعني ترد يعني انه
دراهم
طنشت وخليتها فتره بعدين ترجع له اللي صار
كنت فهل دراهم يكون اظن اقواس ولا لا اه
هل اقدر اربط مع البنوك ولا لا هذه كلها
تساؤلات كانت همم يعني موجوده
احب المخاطره بس همم يعني في مخاطره
يعني غير سنه
كلهم قال طيب الفكره كلها
مباشر همم
فتره
اتكلم مع ناس فتره بنتكلم مع بنوك نتكلم
مع الجهاز اللي ممكن نتكلم يعني
ههه همم
نتكلم على الناس ونشوف في يوم شفنا من
البنك العربي قالوا كيا يلا بنرفض يوم
شفنا عنه
المصرفيه المفتوحه طبعا فكره دراهم كانت
قبل بدايه مصر فيها كانت تطبخ من نهايه 20
20 ديسمبر تقريبا وعلى بدايه 21 طلعت
مصروفين المفتوحه وكانت هي العلامه اللي
يحتاجها فعلا الامور بشكل مره كويس لكن هل
بتخلص بس انا هل بتخلص بسنتين للواحد
مكانيدري همم بيوم بدات تجاوب من البنوك
يوم
المشكله صارت تمسني بشكل شخصي من كثره ال
همم
المقابلات مع الاشخاص ولا المستخدمين
المحتملين يعني همم
قالتهم خلينا نطلع في التايم انا بخاطر في
الموضوع اوكي
تيجي من نراهم ما يجي منه اه تمام
الاف شيء يعني عادي بس انه يمشي بعدين
رفعته ثاني مره ومن رفعت ههه
يعني
متطرف الراي لكن
ما احس اني مقتنع فيها
شركه
واتوقع انا ما عندي اتوقع ان رياض الاعمال
ما ينتظر لانك انت تقولوا لاني اقول ولا
انه يحضر دوره في منشات تقول اطلع ولا
قاعد
تعمل
راتب سنتين حطه في البنك عندك عندك واتاكد
ان ما ادري شلون عشان تسويه
الواحد اذا كان عنده قناه داخليه
والايمان انه شهاده تقدر تم على قولتك
فتوقع الرياده للاعمال رياض الاعمال ناشف
فيها للاسف يعني وانسي انه يبدا ويجرب وها
ما عاد يقدر
ولا احد بيقنعنا يدخل
هو يسويها لنا هيك ويسويها
اااه انت ما كنت اول دخول لك في مجال
المصرفيه البنكيه مع الدراما في مشروع
اشتغلت فيه قبل همم
بالمكان المالي
في المكان المالي يعني هي اشتغلت في البنك
بس كان على همم
الاشياء اللي
فرقه مثلا عن برا مثلا
المسلمين مفتوحه انه نحن مثلا البنك البنك
المركزيه بيشرحها ويبدا تنفيذها قريب وانه
اغلب الدول ما عندها مثلا هذه تعتبر فرق
بس تاخذ مثلا فرق اني انا باسحب البيانات
تلقى في امريكا عشان انا بسحب البيانات
بدي كلفني مثلا خمسه دولار يعني كل 20
ريال
بدي اعرف شو الفروقات اللي بيني وبينهم
الاماكن اللي فيها
وين الاماكن معقده يعني يعني
عندي مشكله مع اني اشتغل معهم كثير انه
ابسط الامور دائما اخلي كل شيء سهل وممكن
وهذه طبيعه فيني يعني لكن فعلا الموضوع
الاصعب صراحه
عاديه وخامه
تشريعي ولا هم جانب المجال همم انه عمليات
اعاده المفروض تكون اسهل لانه خلاص
يسجل دخوله واخذ تصليح اخذ البيانات حقته
لكن في المجال للماليه لا في الموضوع
المعقد بشكل مره اكثر انه لازم يكون عندك
شهاده ولا لازم يكون عندك شهاده لازم يكون
في تصريح للاي بي اللي طالع من عندك ولا
لازم يكون في همم موجود
بطريقه همم البيانات
تعطيه راحه نفسيه للمستخدم
وبطريقه ما تاثر على تجربه المستخدم
في التطبيقات البنوك يعني شو فيها كثير
منهم بقدر انها تشريعات عليهم انه لازم
يسوون اجراءات هذه لازم يحطون العقبات هذه
قدام فكيف توافق بين اثنين كيف تسوي تجربه
خرافيه وكيف انك تكون يعني موافق
للتشريعات وبطليقات هذا اصعب شيء
ههه
جد والله
البنت المركزي يمكن او ان البنوك انا ما
ادري ترى
ينظر اليك
والله احيانا تتدخل
مثلا اني ابغى احول
فلوسي الى منصه منصه تداول
امريكيه
ولا حتى في الامارات موجوده
البيتكوين غيره
يعني
يعني افهم انه فيديو حافظ افهم المره ما
فهمنا مره معقد ان عندي دور انا كحكومه
اني ابغى اضمن انه ما تصير عمليات احتياج
ما تصير عمليات نصب مال الناس تروح مع
فقاعه عندي توقع انها مخاطره عاليه جدا زي
لما ما يسمحون بالتداول في مثلا سوق نمو
ولا في بعض الاماكن اللي يكون عندك شهادات
معينه فيها مخاطره عاليه فيجب انك تكون
عندك معرفه عاليه
افهمها هذا النوع بس الموازنه فيها والله
مره صعبه ليش طيب اوكي انا عندي
تحس المخاطره عالي
ودي انا ابغى اشتري بتكونين
لا والله كل امريكي
فرضيه عن الموضوع انه البنك المركزي عندهم
سمكيرز تمام الرقم اللي تتصل عليه وهدفهم
ما حد يكلمنا ههه لا احد يعطينا اي مشكله
يعني هذا هدف شريف
لو وقفت على كل
[موسيقى]
واحد عنده حساب بنكي لو تحط عليه على راس
عسكري
يقول انا ابغى انسرق يعني انا يعني هو مو
بتحط لها رساله نصيه ما هو النبي تتصل
عليه وتقول هل العمليه اللي انت سويتها صح
يعني
انا يمديني اروح اسحبها من البنك
في اي مكان اختبارات
دخله اذا واحد يبغى يدخل بيقدر يدخل
بطريقه او باخرى لانه بيتحايل على شخص ولا
بالهذا لكن قديش انك تقدر تقلل الضرر اللي
اذا دخل فدخل حسابه اوكي طيب همم احط
عليها ثاني ولا لازم يكلم ولا احط عليها
ليره ثاني انه لازم يسوي وقتي فيه
هالاشياء اللي تسويها اوكي لما احس تشوف
سببها ومنطقها تقدر تتعاطف مع الموضوع همم
لكن برايي الشخصي صراحه انه احيانا همم
تقدر توافق بين الاثنين بطريقه اخرى اتوقع
اقدر اعطي
مثال همم اضافه المستفيد اول كان عشان
تحول لازم تضيف مستفيد وتتكلم وتفعل وهذه
كلها انه حواله انا ما اني محول واحد ما
اعرف حاجه بس حلوها بطريقه اوكي جزء كبير
من حوالات اقل من 2500 فهذا المبالغ عدد
العاديه اوكي بس همم حوالي مره واحده
ويكون بكافه معين ويصير على طول بدون نظيف
مستفيد بدون هذا حل رائع جدا تجربه
مستخدمه ما الصرف الامان ولا اثر في هذا
فاتو كان يحتاج الناس اكثر يفكرون احنا
يعني عندنا لانه دائما في التطرف انه ابغى
كل شيء يكون امن ما همني تجربه عمرها ما
صارت احسن شيء في الحياه بس الفلوس لا
تنسرق تقدر تقول هذه الاوليه الفلوس ما
تروح ولا ما يصير فيها اي تضحيه همم لكن
هذا منسي بزياده ههه
يتعامل مع مبالغ بسيطه مثلا او اذا العميل
هو تقييمها للعميل اللي بعد فائده كبير في
السن المفترض انك يعني
يمديك انت مثلا برده تستخدم
في نمط يعني لما يكون عمره فوق ال 60 فجاه
يضيف مستفيد غريب بعدين يحول المبالغ صغير
حتى لو اخذتها يعني
بس بس احيانا التشريعات
تقهر يعني 100% هو غير كده دائما لازم
تكون على قولتهم دائما تتغير دائما محتال
بيتغير ما في يعني قد ما نحاول نبسط
الموضوع انه خلاص في انماط حط عليه ذكاء
اصطناعي وحاول تتعرف هو بيحل جزء معين بس
مهما كان دايما بيفاجئك دائما ذكرتني في
توك حق موزه برده
يضيفها مره ثانيه تمام
[موسيقى]
اقل من 1% نصف والحاجه طيب مقارنه هذا
الواحد بنيه الضرر كم الاقتصاد اللي زادوا
وكم النفع اللي زاد هل هذا يساوي مقدار
تضحيه هذا ولا لا لانه لو قللت بتقلل
الاقتصاد صح ما سمعت تقدر تحول ناس ما
تقدر
يعني لو قدرنا نوسعها اكثر بيكون افضل
من هذه المستهدفات عنده انه يجب انه يحمي
الناس وما عندها اي همم اهتمام او
انهيات
العميل المهمه ولا لا لان انا رايح للناس
وبس ولا عندي اهم انه يطلعون فلوس زياده
وفعلا يعني يحتاج اننا مشغول كبير كبير
عليه وتوقع عشان كذا صار فيها هيئه تجربه
العبيد اللي موجوده
الرقميه واحده من
اول مبادرات حقتها تجربه العميل تحسينها
بشكل امين في اهتمام قاعد يصير
في عندي مشكله بالانجليزي
يطول يستخدم بس الانجليزي
بالعربي
هي اللي هي اللغه
هذه هو انا اسويها حركه الانجليزي على
خدمه عملاء ولا شيء لو المتكلم
منين اه
وتركها يعني والله
مشكله فعلا
يواجهه فقط
فلو لو يعني تحسبها تجربه تجربه في
السعوديه مثلا المعاملات الحكوميه ترى جزء
كبير منها ممتاز الى حد معين همم ما هو ما
هو سيء بس اتوقع الخلل والتكسير بشكل مره
كثير التجربه الرقميه التجربه اللي في
الواجهات التجربه اللي صرنا نشوفها وتعود
عليها في كل التطبيقات اللي بره لكن ما
هنشوفها هنا يعني شو التطبيق اللي يعجبك
مؤخرا مؤخرا تلجرام يا اخي
مجانيات
فقدت مكانها يعني الحين صار تبغى ناس
يتكلمون عن يعني اخر مثال الاخر تويتر
[موسيقى]
قعدت في طريقه رهيبه
ويعني قاعد تحل مشكله فعلا فعلا تطبيق
اسود
تجاربها وكل ما عليك تكتشف كيف انه تجربه
ممكن تكون اسوى اكثر ههه
والله طبيعي
نفس الميزات نفس الموجود لانه جايه من
المشجع بشكل بشكل
تطبيقات البنوك حتى مع الراجحي وكيف انه
واصل الحين لسه قدامهم مشوار طويل طويل
طويل جدا انه يخلونا تطبيق بنكي يليق
باقتصاد سعوديه صراحه ههه لا الحين ما وصل
هالمرحله بس كفو شغاله يعني
نعول عليها والله يعني بمثل دراهم واا
وغيرها هي اللي احس انها همم
واضح انها مصمم همم
كده يعني
مره مره معقد يعني كذا اصفر اخضر احمر
اصفر
اهلي وايش معنى هذه المعلومات
ثانيه بواجهه مستخدم بديعه مثلا في امريكا
يعني احس انها مره في برده همم
موجوده همم
[موسيقى]
شباب
رائعين ودهم يسوون حاجات حلوه
[ضحك]
ان هل يجي بنك ياكلكم
في امريكا بنت اكبر مؤسسه من اكبر مؤسسات
الماليه يعني تطبيقات كثيره قعدت تنشره
رومانسي
هو يخوفنا من ناحيه انه تخاف انه استحواذ
فقط لحل مشكله سريعه انه عن السحوات خلاص
المفروض التطبيق عندي كويس لكن تعرف يعني
مو كل الاستحواذ هو الاستحواذ ناجح
فهل فعلا الاستحواذات اللي اكيد راح تتم
بتكون استحواذات ناجحات واثر على الهدف
الاستحواذ تحسين انتاجه
ولا فقط
هذا حسن
متفائل انه فعلا همم
كثير من البنوك
اه قاعد تشتغل قاعد تشتغل بشكل مره كبير
عشان تحسن تجربه كثير من البنوك تعلم
مبادرات رقميه و تحور رقمي فا هذا الشيء
ما يخليك انك تفاعل صراحه يا اخي تفاعل
شوفها في الجو حولك كيف انه كل احد قاعد
يشتغل وقاعد يحسن وقاعد يطول فعلا
بياناتهم ممكن يكون في رد فلاكم
متخوفين صراحه
كلمونا ما شاء الله ولك تعال وسوينا
اجتماع مع المساعد المحافظ تعال كيف
ندعمكم ليش ما تجون عندنا على طول قدمنا
على البيئه التجريبيه اقل من اسبوعين جتني
الموافق يعني تجربه صراحه مرتبه ومنظمه
ويسوونها على كذا
مبسوطه
هي كلفه همم بصرف من ناحيه تضيف من ناحيه
يعني انا اتوقع مليون ريال مليون
يكون عندك اجراءات همم
تحرس انه ما حد يقدر يشوف البيانات همم
انه ما احد عنده اكسس مباشره
الباسورد منفصل بين اثنين ولازم يكون في
تصريح معين لانه البيانات ما تكون مخزنه
بطريقه كده لازم تكون همم
في اشياء شغل يعني لما الواحد يناظرها من
المنظور
بتدخل هيا يعني لكم علاقه بهيئه الامن
السبراني لا
هو في يسموها سامه سايبرس سكرتي فريم ورك
هذا كان موجود قبل هيئه الام سبراني ومطبق
على جميع البنوك ويفرضون جزء معين منه
شركات التقنيه مو جزء والله كله
[ضحك]
يعطيك
اوكي لحظه
كم
يا رجال سوي شيء ثاني مو بدر يا رجل
مو فتره انك تياس من الفكره ولا تؤمن بس
يا اخي انت عارف يعني اتوقع انا دائما
اقولها ايش سبب نجاح لاي مؤسسه ولا منشاه
الاصرار
موافقه اللي انت تبغاها اوه تجيك مشكله في
التطبيق مزعجتك بشكل مره كبير يا الله شو
هذا تحاول توظف ناس يرفضون العرض ولا
تحاول يعني اتوقع هذه اكيد
تلخبطه واجد
ايش كمان يعني المحتوى مره صعب ترى الفلوس
يعني انت صح على الاقل عندك مشرع تقدر
يعني بيعطيك ورقه تمشي عليها بالحرف
وحياتك كثير سليم ما في عندي مشاري اعطيني
ايش يبغى بالحرف عشان نمشي ههه المشكله
همم
[موسيقى]
الاستثمارات الصرف التوجه الاستراتيجيه هل
احنا قاعدين نسوي شيء بشكل صحيح ولا قاعد
عندها الفكره
صحيح الاتصال
تاكد انه القرارات اللي قاعد تطلع ولا
الخطوات اللي قاعده تاخذها همم تتاكد منها
مو انك تفترض انه هذا الشيء صح وتمشي فهذا
احيانا اني تعبي يا اخي يتعب خصوصا انك
قاعد تسوي شيء
يعتبر جديد نوعا ما ما هو يعني جديد
بالبيئه اللي انت موجود فيها
اشياء كثيره لازم تجربها يعني واحده منها
تفضل امثله هل كان المفروض ننتظر ليه الرب
كان موجود ولا نطلب رسائل يعني زي ما تقعد
تجربه ما هي احسن شيء في الحياه
معينه بس هلا هل كان المفروض يعني ما
تتصور
نقاش كبير على الموضوع من ناحيه
استراتيجيه ومن ناحيه هذا الموضوع طبعا
جاء واحد
اطلق واستخدم واخبص اجرب وبعدين ترى هذا
يعني مثلا جاك ميت ب 200 الف واستخدم
السعوديه فيها 35,000,000 يعني والعالم في
ثمانيه مليار يعني ههه اسوا شيء ممكن هذه
الفكره حررت شوي بس تجيك تجيك الترددات
هذه يا اخي هي اللي تخليك تشك وتخليك تشوف
يعني اتوقع انك بس تعداها وتتاكد
شويه
صعب
همم كويسه
يجرونكم انكم تحطونا في التخزين السحابي
تكون السعوديه
ما هو جاهز كله لسا مانيوال يعني مره تيجي
تسجل وتفتح حساب وخلاص بياناتك موجوده لكن
هنا لازم تقدم طلب وتربوزه وبعدين يسووا
لك اللوكيشن في اتوقع اثنين اللي هم وراء
كل واحد ثاني يعطيك كده سجل بدون ما اتكلم
احد وتفتح لك بس وصلنا مرحله همم
ضغط استخدام الى نحاول نزود مساحه
ما يكفي طيب اوكي اوكي
انه سيء شغال السيسي مشغولين مع الحكومات
وشركات كبيره
في هذه الشركات الثانيه
الله يعطيك العافيه
اتوقع كل احد شغال الحين معنا ترى عندنا
اجتماع اسبوعي حرفيا كل اللي يقول ليش
الافكار وايش اللي يستخدم وايش الشيء اللي
طلع فيه كل اسبوع واحد مننا يكلف انه يكلم
عملاء بشكل مباشر يفهم المشاكل اللي
موجوده الافكار تسمع يعني فكره
واحد من الشباب حطها بعدين جاء واحد زاد
عليها واحد انا بدي اكتب عنها هذه
كده تسلسل
والله فكره ممتاز اه يعني بس انها تقهر
لانها احيانا ما تشتغل وما عاد اعرف مثل
ما تشتغل واللي يعرف ايش السلوك حقنا ما
تشتغل يعني
تشتغل ايش المشكله
انت اكثر منك
يعني ليش كل هذا عملاء الراجحي هذا
الموجودين عندنا
تطبيق يوفر لهم ما ادري والله يمكن انا
معقده في الراجحي ترى هسه يمكن مثالي
الراجحي ننزل تطبيق ثاني
احمد علي
[ضحك]
البنوك الثاني ههه
للطاقه الثمانيه ههه
الراجحي رصيد حق خطا ما عاد اعرف شو يعني
اتوقع هذه وحده بالاشياء اللي كان ممكن
نبسطها بشكل اكبر خصوصا مع الرسائل ومع
هذا احنا حاولنا انه
نزود السكوب على نفسك اوكي ما بنحط
العمليات كلها تحت بعض لا بنتعرف على
الحساب بنحاول نطلع الرصيد وبنحاول انه
نحدث الارصده يعني عرفت كيف اللي يحاولنا
نخليه يعني وسبب مشاكل مره كثير في
البدايه بس الحين بعدين تتضبط
[موسيقى]
تبغى تدمج بيني وبينه وبكيفك يعني اه نسلك
دعوه ان شاء الله اول ما الراجحي يصير
يعطوني
باذن الله
رهيبه رهيبه
صح هذه هذه هذه هذه شيء تعتب علينا في
يعني بس كلها اولويات يا اخي ترى لو تلاحظ
احنا ايوس بس وفريق صغير مره قاعد احاول
نركز على المنافسكم
[موسيقى]
في شباب
همم
لكن همم تواصل مع الشباب
لكم شكرا لجميع عبد الاحد في التحرير
وعبد الله السحيباني في التصوير وعبد
الوهاب محمد في اداره التصوير ومجد القارئ
في تصميم المكان مساعد في الانتاج اسيل
بافرت وعبد العزيز المزيدي وضياء التونسي
في الهندسه الصوتيه هذا فنجان احد منتجات
شركه ثمانيه للنشر وتوزيع ننشر كل الانتاج
الحب من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع المقبل